uh hey david are trumpists really going
to boycott the georgia senate elections
don't they realize they'll just lose if
they do it
yeah this is a great question earlier in
the week
we talked about how by insisting
that the georgia election was rigged on
november 3rd
and that even though donald trump really
won this is the claim from some on the
right even though trump really won
joe biden was given the election and the
electoral votes in georgia because of
some
theft or or wrongdoing or subterfuge
we talked about how by saying that
you're at least
implying that the same would take place
on january 5th when we have these two
senate runoff elections which will
actually decide control of the senate
rafael warnock democratic challenger
against incumbent
kelly leffler john ossoff democratic
challenger to incumbent david perdue
when you insist it's rigged it's rigged
it's rigged
if people believe that they might say
why the hell am i going to vote if it's
rigged if my vote isn't going to count
if the democrats are going to steal it
anyway i'm going to stay home
and so over the last few days and at her
debate against
raphael warnock you saw kelly lefler
talking about this
they are now going to everybody must
vote
and it's sort of incoherent it's sort of
i guess the case they're making is
it's rigged but if we vote enough
we might be able to overwhelm the
rigging
the reality is that it's republicans in
georgia that have actually
rigged the elections if anybody has
through voter suppression tactics that
have been completely out in the open
voter purges removing people from voter
rolls
reducing early voting hours um so on and
so forth we've been covering it for a
very long time
do i think ultimately that many
republicans are going to stay home
because of the conspiracy theories i
don't think so
i don't think so and before you know
this has actually become a little
controversy
within the show's audience on the monday
show i said
i have been advocating for more
participation and more voting for a
decade on this program
so i'm not going to suggest to
republicans that they not vote
because it goes against one of the
fundamental principles that i have
obviously i would rather republicans see
the light and vote for the right people
but i wouldn't be able to live with
myself if now i start saying stay home
republicans
but i did say i'm not going to go out of
my way
to change republican minds if they've
already been convinced not to vote by
claims that it's rigged
and i actually got a few emails from
people saying david why not tell
republicans not to vote
uh they're voting for absolutely
horrible people and again
it's the principle this is not a program
that activate
that advocates for not voting and i
understand if republicans stopped voting
then uh the left could easily win but
it's
if you know me you know that that's not
how i operate i know that many will say
why aren't you stooping to their level
they stoop to their level and they don't
care well
i do care i do care i i'm taking the
high road on that but
if republicans want to insist that they
shouldn't vote because it's rigged
by all means go ahead and do it and i
would gladly accept
uh republicans losing those two seats
because they believe
that their voting is actually rigged go
ahead but in the end
i think most republicans are going to
vote if you ever feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book
or audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
8 bucks a month and you get the entire
library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video